IT HAS BEEN NEARLY ONE MONTH
SINCE HAITIAN PRESIDENT WAS
ASSASSINATED IN HIS HOME.
NOW, WE HEAR FROM THE ONLY
OTHER PERSON HURT IN THE ATTACK,
AND THE ONLY WITNESS.
HIS WIDOW, THE FIRST LADY.
IN HER FIRST ON CAMERA
INTERVIEW SINCE THE ATTACK, SHE
SPOKE, EXCLUSIVELY, WITH CNN'S
MATT RIVERS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
THAT NIGHT, AND THE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE STILL UNANSWERED.
>> WHEN GUNMEN STORMED HAITI'S
PRESIDENTIAL RESIDENCE, AND
ASSASSINATED THE PRESIDENT OF
HAITI, JUST ONE WITNESS WAS
THERE WHEN HE DIED.
>> MADAM FIRST LADY, HOW ARE
YOU?
>> HIS WIFE, HAITI'S FIRST LADY,
FLANKED BY PRIVATE SECURITY,
SHE AGREED TO GO ON CAMERA FOR
THE FIRST TIME, WITH HER SIDE
OF A STORY THAT IS LEFT HER
SHAKEN.
>> YOU HAVE ARMED SECURITY,
HERE, AT THIS INTERVIEW.
WE HAVE BEEN ASKED, AND AGREED,
NOT TO DISCLOSE THE LOCATION OF
WHERE WE ARE TALKING RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE, OBVIOUSLY, AT LEAST,
THINKING ABOUT THREATS TO YOUR
LIFE.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOUR, LIFE
RIGHT, NOW IS AT RISK?
>> IT IS.
I WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE ALIVE.
>> IN A LONG CONVERSATION,
SWITCHING BETWEEN HAITIAN
CREOLE, AND ENGLISH, SHE
DESCRIBED, AND VIVID DETAIL,
WHAT'S HAPPENED, THE NIGHT HER
HUSBAND WAS KILLED.
IT WAS AROUND ONE AM, SHE SAYS,
WHEN THE SHOOTING STARTED.
IT WASN'T SOMETHING SMALL, IT
WAS THE SOUNDS OF AUTOMATIC
WEAPONS.
BULLET HOLE, STILL POCKMARK
INGA COMPOUND, AT THE TIME THAT
SHE, AND HER HUSBAND, HIDDEN IN
THE BEDROOM.
MINUTES LATER, SHE SAID THE
DOOR BURST OPEN, GUNFIRE,
RIPPING THROUGH THE AIR, AND AT
FIRST, ONLY SHE WAS HIT.
FACE DOWN, AND BLEEDING, SHE
THINKS ABOUT A DOZEN MEN
RANSACKED THE ROOM, LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING SPECIFIC.
THEY CAME TO FIND SOMETHING,
BECAUSE I HEARD THEM SAYING,
THAT ISN'T IT, THAT ISN'T, IT
THERE IT IS, WHICH MEANS THEY
FOUND THEY WERE THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THEY
FOUND, BUT AFTER THEY DID, IN
ATTACKER APPROACHED HER HUSBAND,
AT THIS POINT, STILL ALIVE, AND
UNHARMED, AND GOT ON THE PHONE.
SHE SAYS, THAT PERSON CALLED
SOMEONE, AND DESCRIBED WHAT MY
HUSBAND LOOKED LIKE.
SAYING HE WAS TALL, SKINNY, AND
BLACK.
THEN THE PERSON ON THE PHONE
MUST OF CONFIRMED TO THE
SHOOTER THAT WAS HIM, AND SHOT
HIM ON THE FLOOR.
THE PRESIDENT WAS DEAD, AND THE
ATTACKERS, LEAVING SOON AFTER.
HE BELIEVES THE SHE WAS DEAD TO,
CRITICALLY WOUNDED, SHE LIFTED
HERSELF UP.
>> WHEN YOU STOOD UP, AND YOU
SAW HE WAS DEAD, DID YOU SAY
ANYTHING TO HIM?
>> IN MY HEART, I SAID
SOMETHING I USED TO TELL HIM
WHEN HE WAS ALIVE.
WE ARE MARRIED, FOR BETTER OR
WORSE, AND EVEN BEYOND THE
GRAVE.
HER LEFT SIDE, BLEEDING, AND
HER RIGHT ARM, SHREDDED BY
GUNFIRE, SHE IS LET OUT OF THE
HOUSE BY POLICE, AND COMES TO A
QUICK CONCLUSION.
THE DOZENS OF SECURITY GUARDS,
NORMALLY ON HAND TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT, EITHER LET THE
ATTACKERS, IN OR ABANDONED
THEIR POSTS.
>> THERE IS NO OTHER
EXPLANATION.
YOU ARE THERE TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT, AND THE PRESIDENT IS
DEAD, BECAUSE YOU ARE NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND.
ADDING, SHE WAS AMAZED,
APPARENTLY NOT A SINGLE GUARD
WAS INJURED.
SHE BELIEVES IT IS PART OF A
MUCH LARGER CONSPIRACY.
>> YOUR HUSBAND'S FUNERAL YOU
SAID, QUOTE, THE RAPTORS ARE
STILL OUT THERE, WATCHING, AND
LAUGHING AT US.
WHAT DID YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> THEY ARE.
NO ONE IS BEING ARRESTED YET.
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARREST,
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
PULLED THE TRIGGER.
THEY WON'T PULL THE TRIGGER
WITH NO OTHERS.
SO WHAT WE DO NEED IS THE
PEOPLE WHO PAID FOR THAT, AND
THE PEOPLE WHO GAVE THE ORDER.
>> SO, YOU THINK THAT PERSON,
AND THAT PERSON, COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED?
>> NO.
>> THIS WAS LED TO THE ARREST
OF MORE THAN 40 SUSPECTS, BUT,
STILL HAS NOT PROVIDED A MOTIVE
FOR THE PRESIDENT'S KILLING, OR
IDENTIFIED A MASTERMIND BEHIND
IT ALL.
THAT, LEAVING A VACUUM, THAT
HAITI FLOODED WITH THEORIES
ABOUT WHO KILLED A PRESIDENT
WHO, AT THE TIME OF HIS DEATH,
WAS IN BATTLE, LARGELY
UNPOPULAR LEADER.
EVEN STILL, FOR HIS WIDOW, THIS
WAS AN UNIMAGINABLE ENDING.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT THAT THE
LEVEL OF HATE THE EVER EXISTED
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> YOU NEVER THOUGHT THIS COULD
HAPPEN?
>> NO.
>> BECAUSE YOUR HUSBAND DID
HAVE A LOT OF ENEMIES.
>> HE DID.
BUT, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY
HATED THAT MUCH, TO KILL HIM.
>> WE ASKED HER, ARE YOU
CONFIDENT IN THE INVESTIGATION
THAT IS ONGOING ON THE ISLAND
RIGHT NOW?
AND SHE BASICALLY SAID, NO.
SHE SPECIFICALLY SAID, SHE
WANTS U.S. INVESTIGATORS,
ALREADY INVOLVED IN THIS
INVESTIGATION, TO CONTINUE, AND
RAMP UP THEIR PARTICIPATION.
SHE ALSO, SPECIFICALLY, IS
CALLING FOR THE UN TO CREATE A
SPECIAL INVESTIGATIVE TRIBUNAL
TO INVESTIGATE THE
ASSASSINATION OF HER HUSBAND,
MUCH LIKE THEY DID IN THE MID
2000S, AFTER THE ASSASSINATION
OF LEBANON'S PRIME MINISTER.
BASICALLY, WHAT SHE IS SAYING
HERE, AND SHE IS NOT TRUSTING
THIS INVESTIGATION, UNLESS
FOREIGN INVESTIGATORS ARE
INVOLVED.
BECAUSE, IF THEY ARE N